hey you guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Katie du pape we're gonna watch from
WatchMojo today top 10 movies way too
upsetting to watch twice a Serbian film
will be in there there shouldn't be a
second time around for these films it
will strike on flesh is bread and meat
and blood for Wiegel I will kill
everything my sight
welcome to watchmojo.com and today we're
counting down our picks for the top 10
movies too upsetting to watch twice for
this list you're choosing emotionally
upsetting films based on their plot
points and not because they're horrible
productions or completely gory
that means you the human centipede may
be discussing the final outcomes of some
of these books spoiler alert is probably
in order
number 10 The Passion of the Christ
that's why something truly epic in
nature and devastatingly depressing Mel
Gibson's The Passion of the Christ looks
at the final hours of Jesus Christ's
life and the relentless violence he
endured viewers may want to drink a
couple of extra glasses of wine before
first viewing but watch what you eat
because it may just rise again this is a
film you prepare for process and never
ever watch again pretty bad number 9
Brokeback Mountain gay cowboys
heartbreak 10-gallon hats are you not
entertained
moviegoers filled theaters to watch Jake
Gyllenhaal and Heath Ledger fall in love
but 134 minutes later they left
speechless or in tears sometimes both
that's the place of all wrong but you in
water dance so what we got now is the
line I wish I knew how to quit you has
often been parodied over the years but
who can forget the raw emotion of the
original screen delivery I wish I knew
how to quit you o Brokeback many did
quit you because we didn't want to go
through that all over again
number eight he says this film inspired
numerous be oh so I don't know coming on
its own bathroom accidents based on
Stephen King's nineteen eighty novella
the menaced features you guessed it a
horrific missed along with monsters that
don't necessarily arrived in town for a
cold beer with the locals as tensions
increase a supermarket offers protection
for David Drayton and his son Billy
and although the mist is darker than
your typical horror film the final
moments are simply depressing
I say we trashed off as far as a fuel
takes us a try to kick their ass missed
you are a sick person if you want to
watch this film again sick
[Music]
[Applause]
number seven dance never saw their
finish that for an Icelandic singer an
electronic music legend and the infamous
director Lars von Trier this music
legend Lars von chairman tune unless you
find dark stories of immigrant
persecution a happy subject Bjork won
Best Actress at the Cannes Film Festival
for her performance as a Czech woman
with a secret and her inherently
haunting yet beautiful voice takes on a
whole new meaning by the film's
heartbreaking finale pick your poison
went searching Lars von Trier's
filmography chances are you'll be crying
uncontrollably by the end
number six The Green Mile boss eyeballs
so much what I feel yourself has there
ever been a happy movie about death row
director Frank Darabont makes his second
appearance on our list with a movie
about a prison guards painful past and
the ubiquitous grief that never leaves
told through flashbacks Paul Edgecombe
recounts his experiences with a giant
prisoner named John Coffey
and his ability to heal or take away
during the final minutes of the Green
Mile audiences were crying buckets full
of tears and contemplating what it might
be like to be a wrinkly old person
filled with regret I was pulling forward
the year that John Kofi walked the green
eyes such a heartwarming story but such
a sad one
[Music]
number five in Tbilisi don't need to
hold in 13 scenes shown in reverse
chronological order gasp alloys film
produced some of the most disturbing
images ever seen in mainstream cinema
[Music]
but hey it stars Monica Bellucci and
Vince ah Cassell so it can't be entirely
Vassell well not exactly
[Music]
domitius will be Roger Ebert once called
this film quote a movie so violent and
cruel that most people will find it
unwatchable a couple of guys set off for
revenge actually a character is raped
and well somebody definitely pays the
price it's not hard to miss Elsa cannot
be unwatched nor should it ever be
watched a second time number 4 Blue
Valentine so this is twice it's pretty
hard
how would you like to watch my 112
minute film that will make you choose to
stay single
which makes you insane [ __ ] love Ryan
Gosling
featuring two of today's finest actions
brilliant and Michelle Williams Blue
Valentine chronicles a couple's downward
spiral into booze and aggressive facial
hair this is the dream while the
romantic drama does include some
light-hearted scenes and improvisation
from the actors the film as a whole will
make any happy couple reconsider at the
future you can call me to do so out of
love with you
I've got nothing less for you nothing
nothing it's a Blue Valentine after all
a reminder of how brutal people can be
you know I give you this ring as a
symbol it's a symbol of my saw a bottle
of myself at number three
requiem for a dream somebody cue the sad
trombone because this film includes
nothing but despair when did you start
taking the pills some in fact the
characters in requiem for a dream
somehow managed to find themselves
somewhere akin to Bob Dylan's desolation
well as they experienced a sign to inch
with drug addiction psychosis and
prostitution
excuse my whole life and with sneakers
all ripped up my nose running down my
chin Darren Aronofsky's film about the
struggling Brooklynite will make you
reconsider those minor outbursts of
daily life
it's intense bleak and unforgettable but
we wouldn't say rewatchable
number two 12 years asleep
there's really completed the title one
chef non-expressive McQueen's period
drama to be a jazzy production or
screwball comedy based on the memoir of
Solomon Northup the heartbreaking 12
years of slave tells the story of his
journey through slave markets and
features extended scenes of torture oh
and although its message comes across
painfully clear and allows viewers to
reflect on America's dark history the
worst scenes will cause some to check
out mentally and physically 12 years a
slave is a powerful film that is also
sure to make people cry in public before
we unveil our top pick here are some
honorable mentions okay there is another
who has the joy of having a live rat
sewed up in your vagina you have to help
me please up like I think it's slowly
opening up now people's minds like
educating in and AIDS and
my angel just like women needs to be is
there something the matter with you
number one Schindler's List showcasing
innocent people in danger of being
systematically taken out in the world
Schindler's List is an essential piece
of cinema and a harrowing account of
World War two
much like the equally sorrowful World
War Two flick The Pianist Steven
Spielberg's film highlights the efforts
of Oskar Schindler who saved the lives
of over 1,000 Jews by giving them jobs
at his factory I heard a man goes into
Leeson Institute and they know that
that's true Schindler's List is sad and
difficult to watch but it's most
certainly based on real events by the
historical dramas and most viewers will
simply choose to move on and learn from
the experience
do you agree with our list what movie do
you think is way too upsetting to watch
twice for more mind-blowing top 10s
published every day be sure to subscribe
to watchmojo.com
I'm not contradicting you but may we
re-examine one asset I noted it seemed
to me to look especially pleasing I'm
surprised that Trainspotting is on there
and I'm surprised that Jacob's Ladder is
not on there
I think it's disturbed encompassing
movies that are like disturbing and also
like graphic visual style too like their
number attends Passion of the Christ I
personally really admired a lot about
that film I mean I saw when I was in
eighth grade I was really moved by it I
thought it was a really good new film I
don't want to go into all the spiritual
stuff but I'm not like I wouldn't call
myself like belonging to a religion or a
Christian or something like that but I
still liked the film a lot I thought the
direction was great the cinematography
is awesome there's beautiful music some
people might go oh it's just violent but
it's like that's where the story is it's
in the violence yeah I just love Mel
Gibson - I wish she was anymore
he was put the nail on Christ and that
was his hand give us some facts what
they Brokeback Mountain on this list I
think because they wanted to cover a
large range of why people couldn't watch
a movie a second time I think that this
is the tear-jerking movie I've seen
Brokeback Mountain twice are you it's a
beautiful I can watch it again right now
yeah beautiful you can watch this again
any time that's how good it is that
movie's irreversible I've seen this
movie on a several list but he's just
punching Monica Bellucci in the face
that that desert you can't even see it
but oh my god it's so disturbing at the
very end of the video they showed
another yeah The Revenge moment and that
was really messed up too very revenge
driven I wanted to prove that you can
become successful on YouTube
by doing as little work as possible I
think you've done it and I've done it
welcome to the reaction Channel and Blue
Valentine I I had to watch that twice I
love the performances so much yeah I
think that's the kind of movie you watch
and then you watch again and you get
more from it yeah you don't have to feel
like you have to like close the door and
walk away forever but I heard they live
together for a month yeah something the
same bed probably even [ __ ] each other
maybe most likely if you really want to
get into character you got to have sex
for your co-stars it's my girlfriend
Tommy I understand and respect it and
like same thing with Schindler's List
like Schindler's List is such a
beautifully done film I could watch it
again just I know how like disturbing it
is and maybe heartbreaking you're not
twice in a row maybe you need a moment
to recuperate yeah you want to catch
another matinee of Schindler's List
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Katie Dubois Channel it's a
fun channel with fun [ __ ] on there that
she shits and it's fun you should follow
us on Facebook and Instagram and Twitter
and I have a vine and a periscope
because I'm better you follow us because
I don't know how it might be the proper
placement bit you could sing about the
products like a jingle you could have
your own jingles for the products okay
speaker is green makes you feel mean
first I liked Charlie Sheen you feel
like you're third team you feel like IV
lean okay that's probably enough this
video needs to be less than 15 minutes
copyrights right